hi everybody I think we're really all
we've got the last few people coming in
but I'll start doing basic introductions
my name is Seamus Byrne I work for C net
the technology news website we are
sister site of GameSpot which is looking
after this room this year and we have a
genuinely awesome panel of people here
today I think the audience turnout looks
fantastic I think it is definitely a
topic a lot of people really care a lot
about I think there's so many of us who
wish we were making games but we know
that we have no talent for drawing
things or we know that we really can't
get our head around the code side of
stuff but thankfully I think making
games is about so much more than those
two specific things I'm sure if you know
how to do those things
you could probably go make a game
yourself and that's great but if you
don't there are many many other jobs in
the industry these days and thankfully
we have an amazing panel of people here
today who are going to be able to help
us understand just how much more there
is in this business then just doing
coding and drawing so to introduce the
panel we have will i'll introduce
everybody and then we'll give them all a
massive round of applause at the end
first we have georgia van
kallenberg she is a voice actress you
may know her voice from games such as
Final Fantasy 13 we have Corey Mei who
is a narrative director works for
certain affinity and has previously
worked on titles like the Assassin's
Creed series we have mick gordon a
composer who notably has worked on the
doom games and Sebastian me Tom who
actually can draw I'm guessing because
he is an art director but he's gonna
help us piece together how all these
other things fit into the overarching
world of making games and he is the art
director for Arkane studios the people
behind that lovely little Dishonored
trailer we saw there before and of
course many other really cool games
coming up soon so please thank our panel
so I thought a good place to start and a
way to give ever in a little moment to
kind of explain a little bit about
themselves in their background though
you know we'll try to give it the
elevator pitch version so we don't spend
the whole time on it but quickly just
describe you know individual skill sets
and what it is that you do to help
people make games the start of you
Georgia hi everyone it's so cool to be
here so for me I guess it started with
voices as you're saying so very
fortunate to fall into some pretty great
roles and so for me it's always been
about the characters and about the sort
of front facing side of videogames and
now being part of a few franchises Star
Wars and working with Blizzard and now
taking a star burries game and actually
I don't know if anyone here is a paid a
fan but we're doing a lot of stuff with
payday so what has happened as I started
invoices and now work with star breeze a
lot on the marketing and PR site so
that's something else I can talk about
and the VR world PR PR VR world I should
buy that you're here and I'll come uh
it's probably gone but yeah so I've been
able to explore the side of videogames
that you guys often see once you've been
playing the games the conventions the
community managing the PR the
advertising the marketing so definitely
if that's something anyone has questions
about I can answer that as well as the
voice-over stuff Gary all right so I
feel like my trajectory has been
opposite of a lot of people I started
out working in film and chose to throw
it all away to go into games cuz I love
in prefer games and then I get angry
when I see people working in games that
want to go on and do other stuff because
why would you want to do anything other
than make games
I've worked now twelve thirteen years
primarily involved in writing narrative
direction that sort of stuff so spend
most of my days being told that I'm
really
at what I'm doing and everyone else on
the team we can do it 10 times better so
why am i there and getting paid and then
I go home and drink and so that's pretty
much my job
what I do every day is get insulted and
then drink sounds fascinating there's
something you should awaken it will
unpack these issues shortly me yeah so I
covered the game industry from an audio
perspective and audio in video games to
me is fascinating because audio bridges
the gap between the virtual and the
reality the game itself does not exist
it is a series of polygons textures art
stuff it's all it's all code it just
sits there right none of it is real but
what happens is you take a model of the
character and that character has a
walking animation and we go and record a
real sound effect of somebody walking
that's a real thing so that sound being
tied with that animation makes that come
to life it gives us some sort of sense
of you know authority I guess and let's
much kind of always draw me to video
game so sure especially well so I've
studied in 99 I did find out school so
that that's what drives me every day on
creating world attack in studio I've
been there for 12 years now and I spend
my time like trying to get the artist
better looking at super cool ref trying
to I are the best talent in the world
based on they are special special it is
right and that's how we create cool now
it's the best you know I thought it
might be good to start with you on on a
little bit of a question around how all
these other roles that aren't the art
itself or that you know the coding
itself how that all feeds together to to
it you know help create that I guess a
vision for a game the you know when
you're sitting I guess the tone
you know the vibe all those things I
guess all these different roles have to
come together and build that as an art
director how do you see that whole big
picture fitting together
yeah so that's true that attack you know
I have a job director but I'm really
close to the crotchet or miss miss
mm-hmm and we worked together on
pitching ideas first we try to set the
period of our games and then we'll
follow this all along the production of
the game we try to focus on certain
filters otherwise you go too wide and
you know it became something really real
it's a giant beast to do a games during
four years I think you can say the same
you know you can get mad so if you don't
have filters and tear ours
you you can you know West times money so
well yeah we have oh it's set up at a
Ken is that a try to I especially so
that means architect light it's like in
the movie industry when I started people
were talking about software's polygons
textures and that was not talking to me
because there was an artist five five
years of fine art schools and I felt
that it was not my place and when I came
back I proposed to refer continued to
focus on this as it was focusing on
gameplay gameplay experience or music
and that's how we raised every
department attackin at the same level
you know it has no department that is
above or we are all equal and we we work
in an agile process so every everyone
attacking has a voice we hear everyone
and we try to focus and create games
that are really fun for the players
cool yeah I'm Corey we might come back
to you and get your couch if we need to
shortly for to you know work this
through but I think you know when we
think about the question of being a
narrative director and that sort of
experience within narrow more than just
writing the words that everybody's gonna
say right this is kind of a very
significant part of building out
gameplay so oh yeah so if you could I
guess yeah talk to that sort of whole
you know that whole idea of how
important that whole idea of Ag is
building our narrative and how
more than just the words so I think that
a lot of times the assumption is that
writing their native Direction air
design is focused a lot on the written
word the script and actually that's a
really small part of it and I think that
as you were saying all of the
departments and I've always encouraged
us on all the projects I work on is that
everyone is part of the narrative team
right so sure there may be writers
writing but the the designers that are
designing the artists that are that are
drawing even even the programmers are
coding everyone is is helping to tell
the story and for me just like you said
the idea of all departments being equal
is really important and I think the idea
of encouraging as much collaboration
between the departments is really
critical as well letting letting people
have a voice in the different
disciplines obviously there's a sort of
balancing act between allowing for
feedback and maintaining a vision and
that's like a dance that you do every
day
right trying to ensure that you you
stick to the vision of the project and
you know manage those constraints
because if you if you bring those down
if you don't have walls then people can
go in a million different directions and
you know 90% of those four years are
gonna get flushed down the toilet of
everyone arguing over what the best
direction to take the project into is so
it's a dance between holding a vision
and then finding ways to make sure that
everyone can contribute to that vision
and writing is only a very tiny part of
it even though I think everything we do
whatever department you're working in is
a form of storytelling because we're
making entertainment first and software
like ninth there's a whole bunch of
stuff in-between
yeah make something that and it's just
something I've seen here at the show
which I think is a perfect example
actually of all this that you know
sometimes we might actually assume that
you know it feeds off what the other
guys were just saying now that you know
we should never assume that the coders
and artists are actually yo the indoor
bill obviously if there's no code
there's no game but apart from that
there's a VR game down on the floor
right now called blind where there are
no graphics because you are literally
blind inside the VR helmet and therefore
it's a game entirely about the sound
environment and how you move through it
you know clearly sort of that whole
thing about you know audio is is in some
way it can be the entire game yeah
absolutely is it really quite
interesting I'm willing projects I
worked on recently was a game called
their instinct right was an older game
from the 90s that we kind of brought
back with Microsoft and so yeah what was
really fascinating about working on
killer in cero it's a fighting game yes
it's very very very quick it's very fast
very snappy snap snap snap and um after
the game came out for a while we started
getting some emails from this guy and he
was like telling us how much of a great
killer instinct player he was and how
much you really love the game and less
of a thing and he was like hey can i
play you guys some time we're like yeah
show man no worries whatever so we set
up a match for this guy and we just we
kept playing and he just kept beating us
like everything and I mean we've been
living with the game for about four
years so we're pretty good right and he
just kept beating us and beating us and
beating us and beating his videos we
didn't get off on him once right and we
were chatting to the guy afterwards and
he's like yeah yeah I've been you know
playing fighting games for about 12
years or so I've had to relearn a whole
bunch of things after I was born blind
and I was like what we got a beat like
just non-stop by this blind player and
what was really interesting about that
is that Jed the sound designer on the
project carefully crafted the sounds so
you could understand what was happening
within the game without any visual cues
there's a very important thing for the
reason is that is that instinctively
humans react to a sound first and then
the visual second that's why whenever
you hear a loud bang or whatever you
freak out first and then you CR it's
nothing it's just something falling over
or whatever right so Jeb was very well
aware of that and he'd can't crafted the
the sound in the game to reflect that
and it worked and this guy was a great
killer instinct player even though he
could not see because my brother-in-law
was is that the origin of another game
like this it's called blind nijem so my
brother-in-law is blank and someone
noticed that I was texting doing stuff
on in the iPhone I know people who are
like is it fake or is it a real iPhone
and I it triggered the idea to do a game
like this so it's on the airport's tour
and yeah you move like this just with
the song no visual so that that's the
same question about comm code control I
think it's good yeah that's amazing
so look I think something that you know
helps us I guess get into the idea of
you how you I find a path into you know
this kind of an industry where
you aren't just going through one of
those very obvious sort of doors I mean
you know sort of Georgia how do you sort
of how do you find at the very start you
know that you are able to kind of
demonstrate what you know what what
you're capable of giving to a games
company that exists outside of just the
standard engineering and art departments
well I think now the answer is shifting
a lot because of the community that's
building around games with all of the
streaming and people creating their own
you know indie stuff is popping up the
way it wasn't before I think there's so
many different answers I think it five
years ago if you'd ask me I'd be like
well you if you're doing voices you need
major and then you need a rip and it's
just not like that anymore especially I
was thinking when you guys are sharing
it brought to mind you know the roles of
things like QA and things like that
which purely all you really need is a
passion for games and an understanding
for some of the technical side and some
of the mechanics so pretty much anyone
in here has a role that they could play
in video games purely by being
passionate about the industry and I
think that that's something that's so
special and super cool when you work for
a company that gives everyone an equal
voice because then you come in with a
passion and you get to work with people
that have the coding experience and I've
seen it in the offices where they start
to learn some of the other side and it
is a sharing of experience but if you
talk about voices I guess I had my eyes
open recently a lot when I went to
twitchcon and saw that there are so many
new ways for voice actors to come in but
it really is now a thing where you can
go online and create your own you know
dubbing of a lot of games and that can
be your in when I started it was all
auditions and it was all you know that
one script that came and I was so
fortunate a funny Australian story that
the first role that I got was the big
one which was Vanille in Final Fantasy
and I went in and my agent was like this
is ridiculous you're gonna get this
because they need I live in America and
they need an Australian slightly
American voice early 20s
believes in sunshine rainbows and
lollipops which I do
ah and you know and has this dark past
and I've had a really spotted past of
challenges in my life so it was kind of
like we read this I read for the role he
handed it in sorry I'm taking up so much
time on the story he handed it in to the
producers and said and just put mine and
now for some perspective in in LA when a
role comes out usually 200 300 girls get
submitted at least and you grow to
really hope that they're paying
attention when your voice comes across
but my agent usually submits about 20
people for a role and he only submitted
me and the guy called back and said
where's all your other girls and he said
no I'm not gonna submit you know cuz
she'll get it he's like oh that's super
arrogant don't do that
where's your other girls and he said no
no really she's gonna get it and he said
I'll never work with you again if you do
this and he said okay fine
but she's gonna get it so we're working
together I didn't know this until a year
ago but then like two weeks later Joe
the producer coughing he's like she got
it but it is that thing of sometimes
those years back you were just made for
certain things and there are certain
roles but now just long story short you
can really get into a lot of the
creative side the voicing by creating
going on Twitch and Rea voicing and
doing playthroughs so it's really opened
up I don't know if you guys have
experienced it but it really for my side
of things I mean you could be a
community manager if you're passionate
you can be in the PR marketing
department when I go to these
conventions and I work with all the
different you know booth organizers and
all of that sort of thing they're all
just people that love games and like we
all do and it's an incredible I don't
think there's any industry out there
that's like that that basically a
passion can take you to any role you
really want if you're willing to put in
the time which we all kind of are I did
actually just recently here you ben
brode the game director for for
hearthstone over a blizzard that he
actually got his first job at Blizzard
because he used to deliver pizzas
to the overnight QA team and then they
just let realize I love games to guys
like hey yeah and managed to get a job
in the QA team and it all kind of went
from there so definitely pause like that
yeah it's amazing where they can lead
yeah I mean Cory when it comes to
writing this is kind of probably you
know one of those areas where again like
you said sort of earlier that everybody
thinks like we could probably just write
these words and do these kinds of things
like how where is the where's the infant
for being a writer I think that if you
talk to most people that write for games
they're all gonna have radically
different totally crazy insane stories
so I don't know right and that's always
been my answer is I have no idea how you
do it thanks everybody
sorry I'm just I'm being honest I I
think that that there are more tools
available these days for it so whether
it's making stuff on twine or with RPG
Maker or if there are still modding
scenes out there I wouldn't know cuz I'm
old and broken it's and it's also about
coming to things like pax maybe and and
other conferences and meeting developers
and making an impression and he'll
probably kill me but I'll start sort of
tell the story anyway this is being
streamed isn't it um there was a guy
that used to work here to be soft he
doesn't there anymore he's very talented
writer amazing this guy Jeffrey and he
started out I think the first time I
ever met him was at an e3 and he wasn't
working in Ubisoft at the time and he
just like came up to a bunch of us that
were drinking at the I forget which
hotel it is it's the one that looks like
it's from the 70s and and and was just
super passionate and super excited and
it got everyone interested in his stuff
to take a look and that was how he did
it I I'm always wary of tell a story
because now it's like am I giving people
license to just but you know if I could
do it right it's like she was saying if
your passion about something like if
it's all you care about like do do
whatever you can within the law right
yes don't don't break the law but
but but do whatever you need to do and
and just do a lot of it the the very
first job I ever had in games I got
because I was running a guild in a
online game called Neverwinter Nights
and I'm not talking about the the one
that probably most of you know about
this was like some crazy [ __ ] on America
Online that cost like 10 bucks an hour
to play yeah so I was running a guild
and one day this guy sends me an email
is like hey I'm starting this company up
in San Francisco called a total
entertainment network and we're gonna be
like hosting a lot of multiplayer
lobbies like it used to be very
different I feel so old and and they had
the darksome license from CSR back then
I don't think that even at Jesus and so
he's like you've been a really good
guild master and you run these like
weird events on the weekend and so like
come work for me and so it was just like
being passionate playing games it worked
out this story I really shouldn't tell
and I'll do it really quickly I when
World of Warcraft first came out I was
playing a bunch with people and it
turned out that some of the people that
I was running five minutes with worked
at EA and I wound up getting a job doing
some work there again just because my
whole life is all about
I don't know creating characters telling
stories being a disaster and so yeah I
don't think I did a good job answer your
question just be yourselves and as much
as possible be passionate and and again
aggressive within reason if you're
anything like me it helps to have a
couple of drinks because if I if I
haven't been I definitely can't do those
things I'm kind of wondering if you're
an important part of that story and then
yeah I think this might feed into
something maybe sort of the others can
sort of bounce off but I guess having
that kind of view being bold enough to
go and try to grab an opportunity but
then you know what does that person need
when when maybe they someone does turn
around and buy it and kind of go well
alright then like what have you got that
you probably need something up your
sleeve or something kind of dare to
actually know that you've got a little
bit more to back that up yeah I mean
ideally if you're writing you'll have
writing samples and I know that at least
when I was working
I do be saw for example looking for
people they would say Oh what do you
want to send you want game scripts and
for me it was no I don't give a [ __ ]
like what the format is like semi
whatever best represents your voice an
amazing woman that I hired back in the
day sent me a bunch of like very erotic
short stories that has nothing to do
with video games but the writing was
amazing and I hire her instantly and
she's still working there to this day
I can't say on what sadly but she's
incredible and so lives on the off
chance you're like out there watching
this like I love you she was that she
was the first person that that I got to
hire through our internship program and
so no one knowing that we hired through
that program actually ever submitted
anything that resembled a video game
script it was short stories it was like
diary entries it was analytical like
breakdowns of like pieces of literature
like I didn't care right like have a
voice
make sure the voice is really distinct
and hope that you're not sending it to
someone that's not as awesome and
open-minded but you're right shame is
absolutely the first question out of my
mouth all the time it's like when you
know what send me some writing samples
and it can be anything it can be
anything so so don't worry too much
about you know what what the shape is so
much as you worry about does it does it
best express you in your voice because
that's what I respond to at least so
yeah make I guess you and again in the
audio space people could certainly be
just messing around and doing stuff then
how do you try to get someone to notice
that yeah it's actually jumping off the
back of a cohesive and that as well is
that Cory's story there about the erotic
writing and all that sort of stuff now I
mean seriously like the moral that story
to me is stand out you know stand out be
different if Corey had gotten 200
submissions of erotic writing it would
be the non erotic writing that stood out
that day right but um but yeah so you
know the point is really really stand
out and be different what do I find
these days with the game industry is
it's really really competitive and what
I mean by that is that the industry
itself is competitive within itself so
everybody is working on a big game
they're all pouring lots and lots of
money
find it everybody's trying to have
something that's different that
separates them from the rest of the of
the games that are coming out right so
what they'll do to separate themselves
is they'll do anything they can they'll
do sort of all different so the
marketing thing is they'll hire
different people to work on it they'll
you know work with all sorts of
different script writers and things or
all those people from movies well
they'll do whatever it can be and all in
a sort of effect to try and get their
game to stand out amongst everything
else so that's what a point about being
unique finding that thing that you do
that's unique that that's different
everybody else now of course that's a
difficult thing to give for advice
because I can't tell each and every one
of you what your unique thing is that's
something that you've got to find on
your own and it's really not something
you find straightaway I don't know
everybody's different I guess but for me
like it took took a long time before I
even started looking at music and sound
as something that I half maybe somewhat
knew a little bit about you know it's
like I think you learned through kind of
copying others and things like that too
if you want to learn to be a writer you
rewrite novels and stuff right if you
want to learn to be you know sound
designer right have you learned to make
the Jurassic Park to redirect sound or
whatever so yeah but anyway the moral
that it was really kind of stand out
find out what that thing is that you do
that's unique that nobody else does um
it's the best you know I'm this might
sort of yeah be nice way to feed into
that question that Corey brought up
about just networking as well is I mean
with a studio like a cane are there many
people who you have similar stories of
remember that time we met at that bar
and then we started talking and then we
ended up working together yeah is that a
genuine critical way or you know wait up
for people to stand out and get noticed
yeah it happens sometimes that you meet
like training for example you know we
have lots of trainees
who tries to enter our chem because we
are non studio now and they like the
experience we provide to players and
some of our trainees are no real artists
we the vehicle design for example and
what I tell them in general is look in
to your own story if you want to be
different from other people just look at
you because in general they want to copy
what I see as an artist on forum is that
they all copy themselves so you you see
you can read the pattern of 2016 is
about fantasy character 2017 will be
like vehicle design on the moon for
example I tell them try to be yourself
and you'll be unique because we are all
unique so just look at you in the mirror
and try to bring something if you have
the skills for I don't know writing
drawing coding try to do it the way I
think is the best for you and further
people because then it comes to achieve
work so that's true that when they reach
a studio they are used to work alone and
it's quite different when when it starts
to - I don't know just to crunch with
other people to work with the QA to get
the pizza from these guys yeah obviously
so what yeah that's what I tell them and
from my experience it's that's what
happened to me are rooting through my
past but when I was super young so
that's what I say during the promotion
and of dishonor - I sure a big seesaw
that is no weapon for gang and it comes
from my grandmother she was a terror his
brother was a dressmaker from that I
learned a lot but I realized that like
six seven years ago that it was so
important to crack things this way for
games crafting game or crafting objects
this is the same so that's the flavor
try to bring into our games make things
that look real tight tailored for the
prayer that's I don't ready answer your
question I mean I think it's actually a
great point that it's like if you know a
story like that from anybody's
background that could feed into writing
it could feed into art it could feed
into it so there any any other aspect
there's one word I wanted to pick on for
a minute in the way people can talk
about and and the words been used a
couple of times but I think when people
yeah I guess passion that's the big
thing that people often sort of say yeah
be passionate and I'm sure in people's
pictures and things that often write I'm
really passionate about stuff
so I feel like it's almost in abused
word but you know yeah
Gordon what we've kind of said that the
desire to be in the industry itself is
really good but you know what
are kind of other ideas and maybe you
know Georgia like how to kind of
demonstrate you have passion rather than
just saying the word I have passion yeah
it's I was gonna actually on the
networking thing it kind of actually
connects I hate that word networking I
believe in making friends it's kind of a
different angle but it really is
something that I for everyone in this
room if you're sort of feeling I want to
get in and I don't know how the most
important thing I believe is longevity
like actually saying look I might meet
this person today of packs like you
might go downstairs and meet someone
who's a level designer on some game and
you want to work on that game it doesn't
mean they're gonna hire you next week
but don't give up because if you keep
having that integrity of communication
over the next few years I really love
this game I love I saw that you just
released this you know I like the new
DLC on this game or whatever it is that
you can demonstrate you really it's not
that you're just passionate like
everybody else that says they're
passionate that you really know the game
and and then in three years time when
they need to hire somebody they're gonna
think of you so I think that's something
other than passion really show your
dedication to the industry over a long
time and also for your own sake don't
get down on yourself if you come to an
event or you start reaching out to
people because you came to this and
you're super excited and you start going
on LinkedIn and writing everyone and no
one hires you in the next three weeks
this can take a really long time and
it's worth it because it's what you love
and if you are passionate like you said
in your LinkedIn message to them it
doesn't matter and it will pay off so I
think to be easier on yourself and know
that it will take a long time sometimes
so maybe you will get hide next way you
can awesome
but it's worth really keeping up those
friendships because I've got these
friends that I started with in the
industry in 2008 that now is some of my
closest friends because we both just
continue to touch in on this game or
back I love this you know and I love
that and people move around people move
to different companies and you just
never know what opportunities are going
to come up with a game that you want to
be on
anybody else have any thoughts on that
kind of networking point now we're gonna
we're also we're gonna open up the
microphones to questions shortly I feel
like there's probably gonna be quite a
few questions so don't be too shy or
otherwise you might run out of time at
the end you're warned now there's
microphones on both sides have also to
do the cue thing I feel like that's
probably fairest but anybody else I mean
the things that came come to mind is I
see more and more like you know dev
nights at bars and game jams and all the
like are these are these good for I
guess trying to both you know offer your
skills that it might be a little left of
center as well as just meeting people I
think it's all good I mean yeah um yeah
I think anything you can do really yeah
I mean what's really fascinating is like
you and I we were talking before about
like a networking is just having not
network and making friends which is such
a good points to bring out right a
really good point to bring on but it's
important that it's always happening
you're always chatting to people you're
always meeting new people it never
really stops and these days with with
like the explosion of the internet from
you know 12 years ago 13 years ago or
whatever when we would kick around ideas
about games and stuff it was a lot more
difficult than here so they had to
travel to places and visit people and
things whereas nowadays I mean you can
get paid ugly people up on Twitter I get
jobs through Facebook it's weird I get
like Facebook messages and things and
and land projects and stuff that way
it's it's really weird so it's something
that never stops um just to quickly pick
up on that passion point to you like um
I had passion explain to me once it's a
really interesting way that's worth kind
of pointing out as well passion isn't a
whole bunch of exclamation points in an
email
that's not passion right that's [ __ ]
passion is you're six months into crunch
and you've been awake for four days and
you hate everything and you still have
to find something within yourself to get
the job done and that's that's when you
go yeah that's that's the passion bit
over there um all the other stuff is
just enthusiasm it's just interest it's
just excitement you know to me that
passion thing that's what that's the
thing that comes in the end the passion
I always described as like the thing
that that you do anyway even if you
didn't want to be doing it you know even
if there was no money involved even if
the you know you weren't even required
to do it for any reason you'd still be
doing it anyway
that's the kind of the passion thing I
guess and I mean that's that's a good
point I in I said just know from like
journalism to the side of things but
yeah I think more open to everybody
there that the when you do throw
something back at someone to say well
what have you done if they say I'm
waiting for my first paid job and you're
not to say go and do free work for
people but more that you can do work in
your own time for yourself to then
demonstrate something yeah I'm just
gonna say really quickly like don't do
free work for people you can do free
work for yourself but I know that I
would be very I'm one of those people
that's like if someone said I'll trade
you exposure for work it's really hard
though because I get that I for so much
of at least the start of my career when
I was working in film everything was
done on spec right which was for free
but it was for myself right well I did I
would not work on something for someone
else to enrich someone else it had to be
a project I cared about that I was
working on for myself and I just really
quickly just hearing about you know
hearing the word passion I think that
that the two things to keep in mind are
both sincerity and and positivity I
don't know why I wrote those words down
but I think that when you're
passionately [ __ ] on stuff and
critical of stuff it's so easy it's so
easy like it is so easy to tell me why
like everything is bad and broken and
doesn't work it's much more interesting
for you to tell me why something that
most people see is bad and broken is
actually really interesting or has
something that is potentially useful
down the road I like to say and I will
not tell you what they are in the past
20 years there are only two games that I
did not like and let's be clear I didn't
say that our bad just games that I
didn't like so again at least for me
it's even true for like film and
television for the most part I love
everything so maybe that's a problem
maybe that's why this stuff is bad but
like I like I like a lot of stuff and
yeah so that's all d+ if you can please
any first questions to hit the
microphones i imagine somebody wants to
know things
so yeah the queues on the two sides of
the room left and right side
oh go for it and yeah please make sure
and use the microphone so that the
viewers at home can also hear you yep
I'm the the left
I think they'll turn up the microphone
in a moment okay yep
anyway this one is for our Georgia
because I am aspiring voice actress and
I was just wondering like do you
constantly rehearse or play with your
voices on a daily basis how do you make
sure you continue to have such a
structured voice especially if you're
doing multiple projects back-to-back a
very good question because it is one of
those things where you would assume that
what you have to do is work on it and
like practice every day which is
important of course to know what your
capabilities are but I think you're so
fortunate that if you want to be a voice
actor that's something you can do in
your daily conversation and if you
integrate it into who you are it becomes
a lot easier when you're required to do
it you know room by yourself with this
in front of you
so I've learnt the best way to do it is
to get so comfortable with putting on a
voice in the most random of moments that
like everybody that knows is like you
never talk with the same voice for every
sentence cuz I'll be like oh my god it's
like super crazy and then the next one
I'm like I don't like this and it's just
that's my normal conversation and it
might annoy everybody I know but the
point is that it gets you at a level of
comfortability that is so important and
forever this is this is not just for
voice acting for every single person in
here the most important thing about this
whole panel is self-belief knowing that
you actually have the capability to do
the thing that you want to do and for
voice acting that's something that can
come up even more because you're
required to perform in front of people
or nobody but you know it's going to
millions of people later and it is this
thing of just getting comfortable
being ridiculous that is the first thing
like spend as much time as you need to
whether it's in front of people because
that makes you more nervous or by
yourself because that makes you more
nervous whatever you need to do to be
comfortable with any random weird sound
and then also just like watch things
listen to things and put voices to it
it's the best way to do it thank you
forever machi you're welcome hit the
right side stage right yeah I think it's
okay sorry
so for narrative design you start like
at the beginning project you've got a
lot of work and you're doing things and
you've got like planning and all that
and at the end the ship is burning and
you've got like three scenes cutting
you're desperately trying to put title
together what are you doing in the
middle yeah it's the ship is always
burning the ship is burning before it
leaves port so I wish it was as simple
as you describe as soon as stuff gets
starts being built there's a problem or
something has to change so it is
iteration and and responding to changes
pretty much from go like I said I wish
it was as simple as you as you are
describing because that would be more
manageable but as long as stuff is being
built stuff is changing and ideally you
are aware as stuff is changing so that
you can alter your stuff when necessary
or fight back and tell people that they
need to burn in hell when when they're
making bad decisions so it is a constant
discussion over the course of production
which will occasionally escalate into
arguments but hopefully you love the
people that you're working with and so
those fights are all in good fun so yeah
it's it's you're you're going from day
one and it continues until ship and then
a little bit after when people are
telling you about all the things you did
wrong and the plot holes that are here
and there and you want to tell them that
it's actually not your fault but you
can't for legal reasons you have to just
sort of lay sit on it and apologize and
or not respond so yeah I hope that sort
of answered your question yeah thank you
very much yeah
over here on the web this one was it's
kind of isolated just sort of wandering
with sort of sort of industry moving
along if it's sort of being more people
able to work from home or work off-site
or instead of doing their work more
based in the cloud whether that's
something that you're seeing happening
more within the industry or if there's
the expectation that you might want to
move somewhere where the thing against
you guys are if that's where you want to
end up another very relevant and good
question because it is amazing how
quickly that's changing I don't know if
you guys have experienced it too but at
five 10 years ago you absolutely had to
be in the place that the work was and
now you can set up your own studio in
your closet and record as I have and you
can just submit four things all the time
there is a expectation that you're quite
often able to go in some of the best
things you can do is be in the location
that you need to be like moving to save
being in LA for six months getting to
know people and then being remote once
you've sort of done a few jobs but as
far as all the other jobs go I when I do
everything I do for strawberries I work
from home I don't work I turn up at PAX
I turn up at Comic Con I turn out oh
that kind of thing but I don't have an
office with them so it's becoming more
and more with technology we have sound
designers and all sorts of things that
colors that work off-site because you
don't need to be there and you can put
your Skype screen up and talk to them
the same way that you would really other
than you can't see their legs but if you
need to see legs your leg person for you
um because it really is what I love
about our industry is it's so like you
said it's you can get jobs on Twitter
and Facebook the same way that you can
do the work remotely
so with voices I think there's still a
lot of a lure around having people in
the studio for the bigger things but for
the smaller things that will get you
that experience of smaller paid work you
can do that from home there's a lot of
technical stuff that you need to look in
so just use the Google machine to find
out what you actually need to keep it to
um you know industry-standard but I
highly recommend starting that way thank
you very much on that question Sebastian
like has an art department or you know
overarching since are there many people
who work remotely in a studio like ok
nice day so when I started it was like
'omg developer Noah days you were
working with many with friends but as
the studio is not bigger you need to you
know to get talents from everywhere in
the world and I'll attempt to add people
unborn because I think it's better to
have like to direct contact with people
but that happens that we work with some
people abroad like we have in Romania we
have people in New York but we have
direct connection we have Polycom set up
you know the it's big camera so we are
connected and we are in touch and we
have two studios or one in Austin one in
you and we are in touch every day you
know we connect but that's important you
have to fill people and to face them
otherwise they are just a name in a
mirror you get lost of things and yeah
yeah oh yeah any thoughts from you Cory
we've got a very clean request for you
and again this is just my opinion I'll
be very clear about that I am a big
believer that the best work is done when
when people are together and occupy the
same physical space so just so you know
my dream is that people like you would
be in the office with us so that I could
write some garbage down and bring it to
you and we could record it like then in
there and like be able to iterate in the
in the ways that artists and designers a
lot of times get to do but that
narrative rarely does which is the whole
separate thing for another day so it's
not to say it's impossible right and a
lot of places have done it and they've
done it very successfully and I think
that it's absolutely possible
my preference though for whatever reason
maybe because I'm old is is human
contact and the ability to do the work
but then also ideally go out to lunch
and dinner and drinks and hang out on
the weekend because for whatever reason
I'm the crazy person that also loves
this idea I have this
idealistic belief that the people on
your team also become your best friends
like things are at least their most
interesting when that's true and I think
it's harder if there is distance and
like I said it's just my personal belief
it's not necessarily like the belief of
any where I work and there are plenty of
places that have had tremendous success
doing it remotely but I think like I
keep saying that the words on the page
are only a part of it it's also the
person behind them and I like to like I
said occupy the same space as those
people so the the very short answer is
yes it's possible but I personally
prefer when there's actual contact okay
so this question is for Cory perhaps I
loved original Neverwinter actual one on
America Online back in days yeah that's
not the original one unless you're
talking about like no cuz even like
treasures and gateway to savage frontier
like her nope nope so the original
Neverwinter was this thing on America
Online and you paid by the hour and it
was sort of like a proto MMO so not too
sorry I didn't music I'm very passionate
you actually used to call it o
Neverwinter like for old because no one
knows about it you can look it up it was
a gold box game I just really to do this
if does the phrase gold box game mean
anything to people in here Jesus Christ
that's like well thank you for the
people that raised your hands anyway
continue I'm very sorry I've always been
interested in writing and the only thing
I've really miss fanfics which I've
never published so if I won't get out
there and get people to you know read my
work will be the best way to start by
publishing those things right like isn't
that how Fifty Shades of Grey started
you guys came up but like it's like a
legitimate like vine like I guarantee
you the person that wrote that is like
laughing all the way to like a yacht
yeah so if you yeah so if you write
stuff and you feel it like reflects you
and you're excited about it like get it
out there
now you know like be prepared for some
people to then tell you how terrible it
is like I do every day but that's a good
practice to write for getting a real job
where everyone at the office tells you
how terrible you are at your job so I
would say just get it out there like
self promote right like you hopefully
develop like a slightly tougher skin I
didn't I just drink but everyone has a
different process so I just just do it
right do it get it out there put it out
there hopefully someone will find it and
love it and it's very least like you'll
you'll be able to say like I I put
something out into the world and people
looked at it and and read it I don't
know just do it do it why haven't you
published yeah I guess I've always been
self-conscious
let's go publish it after just go do it
right now you're not gonna die you're
not gonna die thanks very much hey guys
this question is also for Corey I'm a
big fan of stories and games games which
stories kind of like just an excuse for
the game play and I sort of look into
all the narrative aspects of it but it's
always fascinates me because I feel with
a lot of writing and games there's a lot
of sacrifice made to accommodate the
game play to accommodate limitations of
things like game engines what people
actually trying to do with the game play
you know I know you know she grew
Miyamoto once famously said he's shot
down any attempt to try to add more
depth to Mario because he never wants to
be any more than just you know focusing
on the gameplay the princess like you
know what from from the perspective of
the rider what is I guess I guess what
sacrifices are those sacrifices that
have to be made and do you feel that
there are times when do you think like
gameplay of a story is just hard coded
it has to be always that way or do you
think there are times when sacrificing
story for gameplay can actually be
detrimental to that experience so this
this is like a whole separate talk
I guess there's a couple of different
things I believe I don't I don't believe
that it should be story versus gameplay
and if that's happening then there's
like a bigger problem that's going on I
think that as much as anytime you can
say oh it's it's game place fault for
getting in my way it's just as much my
fault for not finding the solution so I
never want to play the victim except to
say yeah that I knew yes so say there's
no there's no like black and white
answer like normally if there's an issue
it means that like both sides haven't
found a way to like come at it together
to find a solution I'm the I will
continue to say in the hopes that one
day it becomes true like I keep saying
that everyone that's working on a game
like no matter to what department
they're working in is part of the
narrative team right so to say that
there's that there's a fight between
gameplay and story means that like
something's gone wrong on the team
because ideally the story reflects and
represents and supports the gameplay and
the gameplay reflects and represents and
supports the narrative have I had to
make sacrifices in the past like yes but
is that the fault of other people or
mine like that's a much harder question
right so my hope is that as I've gotten
older and a little bit wiser and more
experienced I've I've tried to
anticipate these things and sit down
with people at the start of production
and say hey how do we do this in a way
that that makes sense so like everything
else there's no there's no simple answer
but I would like ideally in the future
for us to try and erase this idea that
there is a inherent conflict it's that
it's it there shouldn't be one we're all
working to create the same thing
together and like some games don't need
stories I do think all games need
context though right so maybe we don't
need cutscenes but we at least need to
understand like why we are somewhere and
and why we're doing the things we're
doing yeah okay let me just preface this
by saying ever since I heard you start
talking Georgia I've heard bloody
bulldozer and sit on my dick Clark I go
through my mind non-stop
I'm sorry I just first got into this you
playing Sydney anyway
um how do you guys get past this
self-doubt like you write something and
think oh it's it's not really gonna be
that good even though others will
clearly tell you dude this is some of
the best work you've ever done you
should put it out there and you're
thinking no I really shouldn't this
isn't the best work I mean how do you
get past that stage it's a philosophical
one in talking it self self belief in
the world of video games um it's a lot
of uh gosh I really want to like sit
down with you and give you a cuddle and
talk about for me it really is taking
that leap I really feel that the first
thing you have to do like we just said
to our the gentleman before you just do
it like that's the first step there is a
moment where you have to go if I don't
do this I get nothing I get questions of
should I what would've could it have if
I do it and it feels scary and I'm
wondering and I'm not sure they might
say they like it and that's the first
step so did everybody he really is like
I couldn't have cheered enough like just
do it
and it's a it's the toughest thing we
all know that moment of leaping is the
toughest part but you get nothing if you
don't just a lot of wishing that you had
maybe in years to come so it's just not
that you're gonna feel weird you're
gonna feel scared share it with people
and maybe as a more constructive piece
of advice have like your level of people
that you're comfortable with sharing and
work up start sure and get some feedback
and the most important thing honestly is
to be open to criticism as feedback and
not negativity just let it be that
there's we know one starts perfect like
the first time I did voices is Angelina
Ballerina you know I'm sure there was a
lot of things that weren't sounding
English at all and and I need to know
that so I can get better and it's really
putting your ego away as much as you can
to not get hurt enough to keep going
back in so take the critters
as feedback it's not negativity it's
helping you so go to the people that can
help you first and then work up to it or
just like I do sometimes just go big
alright thanks for that cool I think we
might manage to fit in two more
questions okay so my question is
directed at Mick and I was just
wondering about like being adaptable
when it comes to like making audio
because obviously like the music you
know for now with all the metal and the
grunge and stuff I'm assuming that's not
what you always did and I was wondering
how adaptable you've had to be and how
like important apart that is yeah it's
really good question yeah no really good
question um obviously it's very
important at the end of the day it's all
sound it's all music it's all the same
thing whether there's some tribal thing
where there's some choral thing whether
it's some heavy metal thing whether it's
some country then whatever it's all
music writes all the same notes so all
music starts from the same point it's
the fact that it's music right so the
start of every project I try to destroy
whatever we did previously so whatever I
just did on the previous project that
all gets destroyed mentally I mean that
just gets destroyed every habit every
every process every trick that we've
figured out that all gets destroyed and
we go straight back to the beginning and
that's it and you just relearn for every
single project here thanks one more
question
hi guys first of all really inspiring
hearing you guys because um for me I'm a
I'm a high school teacher so I'm dealing
with a generation of kids that are
coming through at the moment that are
very entertaining they love it and it's
a part of their daily life and you know
for some of them especially the ones
that I come across with autism or some
sort of disability or they've got a
behavioral issue I am finding that it's
a way of communication now the problem
that I'm facing is that I'm also an
English teacher so it's directed at all
of you but particularly Corey I am
having a really stressful time
and I have been for about two years now
getting kids engaged in some sort of
writing process whether it be creative
analytical or expository or anything
else just to get them to flip and right
now besides giving them alcohol
I really need some help because I met my
wits in and I'm gonna start drinking
okay mostly from Cory but then can
everyone else because I've got kids who
are interested in drama music they're
creative they're amazing kids but I just
can't get them to do something as basic
as just put pen to paper at the moment
so what do I do
have you tried seeing about pen and
paper games versus video games stuff
like you know I don't again I'm old so
when I was young it was just done
dragons but pen and paper role-playing
games will oftentimes encourage reading
and writing both on the part of the
dungeon master and the player so maybe
you could DM for your class and they
could you know or you could start out
that way and then ask them to do modules
or almost as assignments I think that's
one way I don't know I haven't used it
that much I don't know if there's a way
to build assignments and ask them to use
twine which is a very relatively
straightforward primarily text based
game tool so again which sort of lives
or dies based on writing so these are
ways to potentially prompt them so at
least if you want to get them writing
those are two things off the top of my
head that might work otherwise my
favorite thing to do and this is like
the drinking so you probably don't want
to encourage you is I think a great way
to practice the craft of writing is to
encourage people to tell really
interesting and elaborate but very you
know safe and I guess lies lying right
you know whether we used to try and go
to whatchamacallit like conventions at
hotels and Bluff our way in or you call
up your friends and see like how crazy a
story you can tell them before they call
you out so those are those are my three
pieces of advice I guess the engi twine
in life yeah I was just gonna get a one
last comment from everybody actually
just on sort of that idea how do you you
know unlock that creative creativity and
then you know how do you I guess try to
really harness it and and and find that
way into the industry maybe start
Sebastian but yeah just those sort of to
really kind of seed of that idea how do
you unlock their creativity and then how
do you find that path how do they
oh yeah but I think as sort of advice
you know yeah what what's your feeling
on on how someone should leave this
industry yeah first trust you trust
yourself as I said look into your past
try to analyze yourself and find your
way because there are a lot of door
opening video games now it's not just we
don't say developers we have a variety
of jobs that happen in the gaming
industry be very social because this is
cheap moonwalk and what I see when
people come from the school there are
really selfish there they walk into
their garage and they are not used to
work with a lot of people and budgets
with tight schedule they don't know what
crunches they know what pizza is but not
the real crunch that we came the night
so yeah try to put in your mind to have
a good general culture and that will
help a lot
keep you eyes wide open look project you
into the future because when we start
again focus on position or two it was
four years ago and when you open your
eyes again when you finish the game
there are youtubers everywhere influence
the world is changing very fast the VR
is there so yeah stay tuned look you
know stay connected that that should
help cool Mick yeah just just be open
don't be judgemental and be really
positive so what I mean about don't be
judgemental is even if you if you really
hate something if you if you don't like
something try and figure out why why it
doesn't work
but you can learn something from
anything just be really really open with
absolutely everything cool Cory yeah
don't give up I know it's hard to not
give up but don't give up keep keep at
it it may take a really long time and it
may be really
otherwise become an accountant I would
drink to it sort of also answer your
question as far as my belief but also
the final words into me form
find a way to make a difference in the
thing you're doing as well so if you're
having trouble getting kids to write
create a game that has a social
responsibility element how do you solve
this problem and I think that that's
something that for me gaming is the most
incredible way to attack social issues
and really look at the bigger questions
in a more fun way which is a great way
to get kids to really problematize
things but for all of you if you can
find a way to connect that passion
including the exclamation points with
what's going to help the world you'll
find the jobs you'll find the purpose
and you'll be in complete flow that you
wake up three years later and you will
have created a game that you didn't even
realize is helping the world or is
bringing forward questions for kids and
for us so really I would encourage you
if you want to stay relevant and if you
want to do something of meaning find a
way that your game or your passion or
the things that you're creating for free
at home on the way to getting a job
really contribute and answer some major
questions that we're all asking cool
what a great point to finish on please
thank Georgia Corey Nick and Sebastian
you